it's um it's good everybody's been
really nice there's been no real hazing
so far so that's good and positive and
yeah it's been good I was gonna say any
hazing no hazing no I mean Oliver loves
to give me a hard time but he plays my
brother so it's fine whatever
he's Oliver okay so tell me about who
you play I play Maddie she is Oliver
Buck's sister I guess character name is
buck um so she's his sister on the show
and she comes in pretty broken and in a
lot of turmoil because she's on the run
from a very abusive relationship and she
needs to sort of hide and she's a
background as an ER nurse for the last
eight years so she really wants to be
able to help people and sort of move on
with her life but she can't do it out in
the open so her brother comes up with
the idea for her to go and train to be a
911 operator and how are you finding the
balance like you have two little kids
how are you finding the balance with
this dramatic show I'm still finding it
it's it's a chuckle but it's been good I
mean I can't really complain and get to
work in LA I get to put my kids most of
the time to bed at night and see them in
the morning
and they're handling it really well they
think my work is hysterical and like my
daughter just loves to come and steal
cookies and my son loves to run around
and see like the New York Street on the
lod and they're having a blast it's more
of me who just misses them a lot during
the day no I saw the dramatic trailer
for the you know I mean earthquake I
don't I mean we live in Los Angeles why
do I want to go to work and pretend that
there's a giant I was like guys we have
to stop this episode and just like move
on now let's go to something positive
yeah it's been really intense so it's
kind of everybody's worst nightmare that
lives here yeah and we're so happy to
bring it to you so yes enjoy yeah
are you ready personally for you no no
I'm not ready I'm ready to move already
I mean I'm ready I have all the kits I
have all the stuff but now I'm not ready
okay so tell me about I heard you say
that you're on episode three you're
shooting so what is Maddie gonna have
romantic entanglements yet not yet she's
um I think she's gonna spend pretty much
the whole first season on the run and
then I don't know what's gonna happen I
don't know if there's ever gonna be a
moment of closure with that relationship
I don't really know what's gonna happen
there
what do you think it is that there's
this fascination with 911 and their
because the show is doing phenomenally
well you know I think Eddie any show
that can truly tap into the human
condition and the heart of the matter
and get out of just the head resonates
with people because I think that
ultimately the world is in an
interesting place and life is hard and I
think we want to feel good and we want
to be able to connect with people and
with we want to sit down and watch
television and be scared and be taken on
a ride but we also just want to feel
good and like the people that were
watching and I think this show does that
really beautifully because it's not just
about the accidents that people are in
but it is about the people who are
helping them and how they deal with each
other in those situations and it's
really beautiful why did you choose to
come back to TV I know you know you work
you do have little kids well what was it
about this project I mean I love Ryan
Murphy I've known him for a long time
and you know when he calls and asks you
to do something you're like ah yes okay
what time am i showing up so I was
really happy about that the cast is
amazing I really love the show I
genuinely think it's a it's a beautiful
show and it felt like the right time my
kids are old enough now that they're you
know going to be going to school and I
think it's important for them to see a
full a full human being who can be a mom
but who can also you know has had a long
career and can go and do those things
and I was ready for them to know that
about me as well now there's so much
going on right now with the reboots of
shows and there's been so much talk for
ever since the show ended about a party
of five reboot and now it looks like
there might be a new cast yes they are
doing a reboot but without us so I am in
if the friends cast wants to reunite and
like create like another character I'm
available I know it's really that's
really the that's really the Ruby reboot
I would like to be on anyway so I'm
happy about that but yeah I don't know
what's happening with the party if I
think we're not invited I don't know
what's going on it's rude that's all I'm
saying but I'm gonna watch I'm excited
about it